Okay.
Hey, what's going on? Is Bill burn is
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 11th, 2015. What's going on out?
Why? Yeah. Um,
I'm out here in Boston and
I am for shows into my,
uh, 19 show run here at the Wilbur
theater. Uh, having a good time so far,
running into a bunch of people I went to
high school with, worked with. I had a,
I had a math teacher from ninth grade.
He showed up,
you know, Algebra, Algebra,
my Algebra teacher,
you know, and I remember that year
you was supposed to get a, uh,
okay,
well shit, you needed a 70. That's what
you needed. You needed a fucking 70,
just like my helicopter tests needed a
70 to pass in order to go on to geometry,
more math that I was never going to use
in my life because I was not going to be
an engineer. I had no idea what
geometry was when I took it.
Nobody ever told me they just fucking,
you just showed up and they just started,
you know, you had to memorize
paragraphs about shapes.
The puck Phi Fag. Urie I'm theorem
or some shit like that, right.
Opposite angles are congruent number,
all of that number of,
I don't even know if it's like
that for you youngsters out there,
you fucking youngsters.
Okay.
But the way that they go into math,
and you can tell right now
that I didn't get the seven,
um,
the way that they go into
math in fucking high school,
it's absolutely ridiculous
because up until then, you know,
it's one plus one is two,
two times two is four.
Four divided by two is toe.
It's all fucking numbers, right?
And then all of a sudden you get
to your, your fresh release. I did,
I got to my freshman year. Um, you
know, sure. If you're from Asia,
you got to this and the fourth grade.
But I'm a white guy.
I got to it in the ninth grade.
Okay.
I got a regular road,
fucking meat and potatoes,
little stewed carrot fucking
brain. I can't help it. All right.
My ancestors boiled the food. There was
no nutrients in it. And as the result,
I'm five years behind an entire continent.
Evidently
everything.
How great it is that we have nuclear
weapons so we can actually bullied people
into actually thinking that we're an
intellectual factor. You know what I mean?
I mean, seriously, if we actually, if
the world was like a fucking sat test,
we really would not be doing well.
Oh yeah.
I'm dragging my whole country
down with my stupidity.
That's how fucking arrogant I am.
It can't just be like, hey bill,
you ever think that maybe you're a fucking
moron who should've hit the books a
little bit harder? No, no. I
don't think that. I think I'll,
I think I'll blame my whole country.
I'll blame the whole school system.
That's what you do, right? That's
what you do as a parent. Now,
when you have a little cunty kid who
needs a swift kick in his little Oshkosh,
but gosh, fucking stupid. Oh,
aren't those adorable overalls? Oh,
the overalls are adorable.
That little fucking monster in them.
You know who's never been told he's wrong
his entire life. And then he's special,
right?
That fucker right there.
And he's the pacifier slapped out
of his fucking face and sorry,
losing my voice already. Hey, I'm
losing my voice already. You know,
I got another fucking
20 shoes to do. Um, as,
it'd be funny thing to say to
some parent, excuse me, Miss,
if you don't get that kid under control,
I'm going to slap the past if right out
of his mouth is not illegal to say that.
That's what's funny.
It's just not,
everybody has like a cell phone camera
and then they would fill you like fill
your film you while you did it,
and then they would do the provocative
to try to get you to watch the video.
I was sitting on a park bench having a
great time with my toddler and I never
expected that. Or then you won't
believe what happened next.
Then they would just cut to me a lady,
if you don't shut that kid up,
I'm going to slap the pacifier out of his
mouth and then everybody would come me,
right. They come at me like I was
the next Mussolini, you know, never,
never once, just going
like, Hey, wait a minute.
The video kind of started with
him threatening that child.
You know what I mean? Threatening
the mother, uh, you know,
to do fucking violence to the kid.
That's where it started.
Like what happened before that,
you know, that's what they never,
they never had that part in the video.
They never had what happened before.
It's always escalate.
Just starts with somebody slapping
a pacifier out of somebody's mouth,
you know, and admitted like I watched
those videos and I go, hey, come on man.
You know, at least wait til
the kids like four. Right.
But these fucking videos,
it's always starts like right there.
It's like what happened right before that,
you know,
for all you know,
that's like a video shoot and the
person's read enough like a cute card. Oh,
you hear that hammering?
I've been hearing that since
seven in the fucking morning. Yup.
I mean you go, cause I'm fucking stay
in with the beautiful mind right now.
Fucking add out to fucking up
to God damn trees. You know,
there's one thing that's funny. People
really talk about that fucking Bang, Bang,
Bang, Bang, Bang, Bang, Bang. I've been
hearing that since seven in the morning.
Yeah.
That fucking
just laying here seven in
the morning and I'm fucking
okay
as well here. Bang, Bang, Bang,
Bang, Bang, Bang, Bang. Right.
And it's making me have all these fucking
weird dreams. I had this one dream,
you know,
because that hammering
that fucking hammer rag
woke me up at seven in the morning.
My first words,
my first words today,
where are you?
Are you fucking serious?
That's how I woke up.
Now you know it's going to be a raw taste.
Gonna be a rough one.
That's the first fucking
thing. And I just, you know,
I was going to wait till the fucking,
you know,
you know the newspapers on the
fucking deck would done and you know,
reading it and trying to figure it out.
But I figured, you know, fuck that.
I'm just going to do the podcast
while the hammer is going on.
I got other shit to do fucking so I got
a deal with it means you got to deal
with it. They get that one in. I'll go
ahead now he's got to go cut another one.
So we've got a nice fucking
10. Oh No, there it is.
Bap, bap, bap, bap,
bap, bap, bap, bap, bap.
Um,
Jesus fucking Christ you fucking times.
You got to hit it before Ted.
Um,
anyways,
so it was causing me to have
all these fucked up dreams.
I had this fucking dream
that me and Nia split up.
I didn't realize it in the dream.
I knew I,
I dunno when I was out drinking with some
other comics who I don't even know who
they are and the dream and I woke
up the next day, they like, dude,
what? You know what the fuck happened
to you last night? And I was like,
what do you mean what do you mean is like
you were doing the chicken dance with
that check? And I was
like, uh, I don't remember.
I vaguely remember doing
it and I was embarrassed.
I don't know what the
chicken dance is either.
That's the weird part about this dream.
And then all of a sudden I was just in
this relationship with this fucking woman
who I didn't want to be with and she had
this weird look on her face and she was
walking weird. Okay. She
had like blonde hair.
She had a weird look on her face and
it was like she was walking the whole
fucking thing. I was going
to, what am I? What did I do?
I broke up with me and I got what?
This,
she's walking weird and we're
doing the chicken dance.
I want to get out of here now all of
that came from that fucking hammering.
I had that thing and
then I had another dream.
I was pulling up to some department
store in the hood for some fucking reason
cause I wanted to shop right.
And these guys going, hey man,
why don't you just park right here?
Why don't you park?
You know I parked in the spot and
then they came up, they said all this,
this spots for our church. Why don't you
go park down the street? Oh, we'll do it.
We'll pocket. I was like, dude, I'm not
giving you my keys. And the next thing,
no one of them was in the car and I
was outside the car, my cake, you know,
give me the fucking keys back. Right. So
I go into this Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam,
Bam, Bam. So then I fucking
go into the department store.
No, Jesus Christ. It's the same
fucking nail. That's what kills me.
Funny if I go down there and he's
banging his head against the wall,
trying to get all the voices out
of there. Um, so I fucking, uh,
I go into the department store and it's
just a shitty ass place and just like
washers and dryers and stuff.
And then all of a sudden like five
of them come in and they go, uh,
a, you know, you know,
we've got to move your car
or something like that, but
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
You know, gimme the keys and I'll go,
I'm not giving you the keys. And they go,
why? I go, cause I'm not the white guy
from def jam. Like, Oh, okay, here you go.
Here's my fucking keys. Go move. The
car, I'm not moving the fucking car.
And then I saw this whole part of the
store that, and then they go though,
you didn't have to buy anything here.
And I go,
and these are all good and
all this fucking stores sucks.
And then they showed the bar,
all the good clothes where I was,
I call it shows up.
This fucking store is actually good.
I know it's a fucked up dream,
but I got hammered in my head is just
as I'm sure I've done dreaming here.
So I ended up going out and my car's gone.
I walked down the street to where it
is and they'd fucked up the fender.
Now I'm driving away. No, I got in
it and somebody came up with a gun,
was trying to rob me.
I remember I just said,
go fuck yourself.
And now when I was walking away
and there was like this Asian cop,
I swear to God would like the Baltimore
riots playing on a TV or something.
I don't know why I had this dream.
Right.
I'm fucking walking out and this Asian
cop, I'm going, you see these guys,
when you going to,
they're going to fucking shoot me.
And he said something even like this fish
sandwich. And it was just like, yeah,
you know I can't fucking help Ya.
Ya know, we had the white shirt on,
you know the fucking police chief.
He was just like, yeah, you know,
I can't help you out.
And then they were saying they were
going to follow me and I said, I,
I said that I didn't give a fuck.
Go Fuck Yourself.
And then I was on sunset boulevard and
I drove home to a different house and
then I walked up,
I woke up and I had a fantasy about
having ridiculous security and I popped up
on that gps screen and all their fucking
phones as they were pulling up the
street. And I just yelled at
him with his goats head on set.
I was in the Illuminati and they got
scared and they left. That's my morning.
This is what happens when
you wake up to hammering.
I don't know what any of that means,
but I got to tell you,
it's fucked up as a second.
Dream was the first one was scarier.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Even in my dream.
Why don't I just say, Hey, you know,
I'm sure you're a lovely person
to somebody else, but not to me.
I don't want to be in this anymore.
Okay.
All right. It is you and it's me.
That's my new one. Instead it,
it's not you. It's me. It's not me. It's
you. It is me. And it's you. All right?
It's fucking everybody. Thanks to
you. It's not working for all of us.
The ununited way. Um, so anyways, um,
you know,
I'm thinking about this fucking add shit
coming from a family where everybody
sort of has it a little bit to
different degrees, you know what I mean?
Which just causes you to constantly be
going in a different direction every five
seconds and all that type of stuff. I've
actually made peace with it and I don't,
I don't think it's really a big deal.
Okay.
I just really sat down and I
thought about it, you know,
as they're trying to put you on medication
in my wife one time I was just going
like, you know, they got stuff, you
know, kind of takes the edge off,
fucking chills you out a little
bit. And I was like, Hey,
you want to your fucking mind,
I'm not taking that stuff. The,
the fucking FDA doesn't
even exist anymore.
It's full of a bunch of people who
used to work for drug companies.
You've got the nuts run in the nuthouse.
I'm not sticking anything in my
fucking body other than aspirin.
Anything that wasn't made pre 1960s,
I'm not sticking it in that
unless I have a terminal disease.
And at that point who gives a fuck?
I'll try anything.
Um,
so
I actually had this
conversation with them go.
Do you ever think that having
add is actually natural? I mean,
I was born that way.
You know,
for you to sit there and like they have
the way that they demonize that. Oh,
people, they have problems focusing
and they can't do well in school.
Who gives a fuck? I didn't do well in
school. I did great in life though.
You know what I mean?
The with the fucking schools in most
jobs is what they want you to do.
They want you to not be thinking,
don't be fucking going all over the place.
And they were like, oh focus on this job.
Focus. Focus on what job is. Mind numbing.
Fucking horseshit. That's not
fulfilling me on any God damn level
stack of spreadsheets.
Do you think I fucking laid in bed as
a child and that's what I thought about
when I dreamed someday. Oh, some
day. What are you going to be Billy?
He's going to be an astronaut.
You want to play baseball?
No,
no.
I want, I want to stack of
spreadsheets and here's the thing.
There's some people that are fucking
into that and it gets their juices going.
Those are the people
should be doing that job.
I got to meet with this
fucking pilot shit.
I had no idea how much I was into reading
charts and graphs and stuff and like
the temperature dewpoint and that
whole fucking formula rights,
subtract attempt that do point from the
temperature divide by Paul 4.4 and then
multiplied by a thousand I thought I'd
hate that shit. I fucking loved it.
Once I got it down and I started getting
the right answers and I really started
thinking about the genius of the House,
somebody actually came up with that got
my fucking brain going and I loved it.
You know what I mean? Which brings me
back to fucking math and high school,
right?
Math in high school, how all of
that shit is fucking unbelievable.
They basically beginning to make you,
the math that you learned in high school,
at least in my fucking country is they're
making you like a junior member of the
free masons.
You know you're starting to learn the
secrets of the universe with that math.
Now, if they fucking said that to start
it out and you know, fucking motivated,
I would have been
this,
this math that you're now
going to embark on that shit.
Then we fucking taught IA for the first
eight years. Okay. That's just, you know,
that's just when you go down the street,
you buy a loaf of bread,
you make sure they give you the
right amount of change. Okay.
Now this shit I should have been up there
wearing like some fucking, you know,
secret society robe dimming the lights
with a flashlight under his chin.
Right?
Just to kick it off
and just be like these,
these formulas we about
to show you showing like a
video of like the fucking big
bang and the solar system and all that
shit be in made the math you'll about to
embark on all the mysteries of
the world up until this point,
the mysteries that we have unraveled the
answers to all of these mysteries will
now be at your fingertips.
It'll be in your mind.
They, oh yeah, you're so right. I
would've fucking ace that class.
He just fucking walk in day one and
you write the name on the board and you
start throwing the alphabet in
words and with numbers, you know?
Oh freckles in the back of the
class. I just shut down. I was like,
I won't put the fuck is this, what is
this? I don't get this. I feel stupid.
I know I'm going to make the people
around me laugh. So I needed as a 70,
I needed to 70 to get through
this motherfucker. Right.
And I ended up getting like a 68 and I
was a Douche to the teacher all year.
Bad move,
bad move when I'm coming up there with
my lack of a hat in my freckled hands and
uh,
I'd like to 68 or 69.
I was right there and he
didn't give it to me and uh,
and I went to summer school
and I was just like, Oh man,
this summer it's going to suck.
I had two weeks off and then immediately
I was fucking back in, into, uh,
into summer school.
And then I got to summer school and
immediately it was the best time I have a
fucking had in my life because summer
school is filled with a bunch of class
clowns, musicians, artistic people,
people with fucking add and people
who fucking hate authority. It was,
it was one of the great
classes I had ever been in.
They did this. I'm at, you
know, I thought I was funny.
I got to those classes. I was, I
wasn't even, I kept my mouth shut.
I couldn't even keep up with the level
of funny that was in those fucking
classes.
And uh,
and then just the balls that the kids
had truly found kids that didn't give a
fuck. It's probably the bad
crowd, but you know something if,
if you take what you learn
in that with that attitude,
if you apply it to the right areas of
life, um, it actually can work for you.
Be apply it to the wrong areas.
He ended up in jail. So you know,
you got to kind of navigate
those fucking waters, you know,
if you know, if your natural
reaction to somebody coming in going,
can I can settle down, can I
have your attention? Please.
If you're natural reaction is fuck this
guy. That's not exactly a bad thing.
You know what I mean?
It's not actually a good thing either.
You just got to know when you got to
know when to say, fuck this guy. Oh,
who is this guy?
Or Why am I listening to this guy?
I think you should always think,
why am I listening to this person?
Unless you know you're on some hike
through the forest and you with some God
damn ranger and there's a grizzly bear.
And he turns around and it'd be like,
okay, listen, this is really critical.
You know? Then you listen. You know,
it'd be like,
who the fuck are you to tell me
Dude? I know it's a fucking bear. Um,
so anyways, that fucking a Dee
Dee shit. If you have a date date,
don't let him put you on fucking
medicine. I'm really going like, goes,
it's Suzanne Somers that got in trouble.
It was one of those Blondie's.
It was the chick from the
MTV thing, right. She said
a bunch of stuff where she,
you know, didn't really do her
homework. Um, what was it on? Um, um,
autistic kids. All right. Oh, is it
Tom Cruise talking about psychology?
I think I'm doing this right now.
You know what's that?
The phone ringing a Jesus.
There's the phone phones ring
and once the hammer and stopped,
then the phone goes
thousand one one, 1002,
1003 1000 rings. Come on,
give me four over under,
I say six before it's picked up.
Come on.
Five.
It's five. It comes to
push ties. Loose ties lose.
It's six, seven for the wind.
Come on. Seven. Come on you seven.
Yeah,
we got a winner.
I'm gonna wait till this is done.
This,
there's somebody downstairs sitting
right next to the phone too.
That's the funny thing. Anyways. Um,
yeah.
Oh, fucking add thing where
it's just like, all right.
You gotta look you gotta you know,
you need to calm down.
We need to focus maybe a year of,
you're a different kind of person.
You don't need two years of a fucking
language and go through all of that
bullshit. Hammer, Hammer,
Hammer, Hammer, Hammer, Hammer,
fucking Christ. Unbelievable.
Unfucking believable.
Constantly fucking places
under construction.
I don't think I've ever been here
where it's not under construction.
It's a beautiful mind and
it needs to be occupied.
Let me go build some shit.
Hello. Do you know me? Sure.
We all do on that person. Hammering in
fucking [inaudible] seven in the morning.
Not a fuck do I get out of this?
Sorry. Hold on a second. Close,
close and save.
Close and discard.
Just fucking apple products. They always
got all these questions. All right,
let's read a couple of ads here for this
week. Oh my God. Here we go. Me undies,
me undies. No more sweaty
balls. Me undies. Mandy's.
Pull them down in a bathroom stall.
Take a dump and maybe a pice.
Look what you're doing or you're gonna
Miss, but it's not your fucking toilets.
Somebody else got to clean it up. Oh
yeah, but you fucking balls feel good.
Fuck them if you didn't want to do it.
You showed us studied in
class so you didn't have to
clean up the fucking toilet.
All right,
90% that's the percent of your life
that you're in your underwear there and
underwear.
It gets old fast.
You know that feeling of
putting on old saggy underwear,
you need to know the feeling of great
fitting underwear that is two times softer
than cotton. You need to know
about me, undies, me undies,
the even dry out your clam mountain,
a bad way.
Me undies is the most
comfortable underwear you will
ever wear and it's insane
how good they make you feel.
I'm wearing some right now
and I'm slightly aroused
and I'm not thinking about
anything sexual.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you and
they literally pull moisture.
Rouse away from your skin sees stay cool.
I have mine on right now and I'm floating.
They have a cool style.
They have cool styles and both men
and women and they all look great.
Check out the photos for yourself.
You fucking perverts it.
Me undies.com this quality would typically
retail for two times to me, undies.
Price, rarely. No retail middlemen
means more savings for you.
Here, here everybody. I
will make it easy for you.
Go to me undies.com/burn and get 20%
off your first order and free shipping.
Save even more.
If you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy
with your first pair or your first Paris
free. You gotta be happy with them when
your first pair is free. All right,
there we go. Next one. Okay. Oh,
here we go. The old favorite.
He had dollar shave club there.
You've heard me talking about Dell Dollar
Shave club.com having you the company
that delivers amazing razors,
razors for a few bucks.
I know a razor that costs a
few bucks delivering what?
A razor that costs a few bucks.
Delivering a great shape.
Seems too good to be true, right? God,
this is going to be bad this week,
but you really have to try the razors.
I'm going to go slower.
The dollar shave club.com raise our kids
made the most amazing shape I've had in
years. Don't pay triple
the price. Everybody.
When you can get a fantastic shave
delivered for just a couple of dollars,
you'd have to be an idiot to
keep overpaying. By the way,
I always say everybody when I feel like
I'm fucking gonna fuck something up.
Helps me slow down.
I'm a massive celebrity everybody,
and I'm constantly getting my
picture taken by the Papa Rizo. No,
I'm not actually,
or I'm on some TV show in high definition.
I can't be seen with Nixon
cuts all over my face.
I have to shave with a high quality razor.
Don't be fooled by the price.
Everybody.
These razors are legit
and you'll never go back.
Plus the dash got me confused there.
Plus they've got doctor Avizia see shade
fucking boner.
It's phenomenal.
If you're still using old fashioned
shave foam, you're a loser.
And I actually feel bad for you. I'm
sorry, my voice is going to go this week.
Everybody. Two shows a night. Hey, I'll
tell you a rough one. The dollar shave,
try dollar shave club.com/bar today to
get started. You wish you did sooner.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr
dollar shave club.com/burr.
All right, what do we got left?
Two down, two to go. I liked it.
I like a little cemetery.
Hey, little symmetry. Never
heard anybody, you know. Um,
all right, so here we go. Back to the
fucking Monday morning podcast here. Um,
all right, so when we, when you,
when I last talked to you and I'll let
when I checked in on you on the Thursday
afternoon, Monday morning podcast
just before Thursday. Um, by the way,
if you would like me to read or rant
about something and I'm talking about
anything on the podcast you'd like to
try to get it on, just tweet me. Um,
with the Hashtag t a m m p
basically Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast bank,
bank, bank, bank, bank,
bank bank. Oh God. Oh my God.
Anyways,
if you'd like to do that,
that's what she can do.
All right. And then, um,
the fuck else was I talking about? Where
the hell was I going with this? Oh yeah,
one of the Thursday afternoon
podcast, money, money
podcasts just before Thursday.
Um,
I was ranting about the Tom Brady thing,
which I cannot believe
they're actually going to,
the rumor is he's going to get suspended
for two games for, for pure speculation.
I love all you guys too,
that show those text messages,
like it's damning information.
I can't tell what they're talking
about definitively and neither can you.
All of this would be laughed out of court.
But the thing is, this isn't a court,
it's a corporation.
And what they really,
what corporations really give a shit
about is the opinion of the base level.
Mouth Breathe and fucking moron.
Because that's the guy you get
the most fucking money out of.
That's the dope that shows up to the game,
dressed,
wearing everything but helmets and cleats
goes down to the pro shop and buys all
this stuff and paints his fucking face.
Moron.
Fucking mole. New booger. Biggest
Fan. Oh look at me. I'm a fireman.
Put me on your shoulders. Even eat fucking
woke up. Even he woke up after a while.
So this is fucking stupid. It's not
worth it. But those are the people.
Those are the same people that call
in sports talk radio and all that.
The fucking NFL is going to base.
Maybe he could have probably,
but we can't prove it.
Report is they're going to base the
suspension on the crowd's reaction,
the base level, mouth breathe, moron.
So basically if you make
enough fucking noise,
they're going to suspend this guy
for absolutely fucking nothing.
You know, I don't know if he knew.
I don't know if he didn't know.
And that's to say, everybody can say
the same thing, but I can tell you this,
he what he, what he did, if he
even fucking know is, is the,
it's the equivalent of fucking,
he played with a hockey stick with too
big a curve on it for about a period and
a half.
And then after that with the regulation
stick scored 50 fucking goals.
But you're going to be like, oh
no, now fuck his whole career.
And all that comes down to is you
fucking cunts hate the Patriots.
And you hate the fact that they're fucking
winning. It's the dumbest shit ever.
And I'll tell you this though, but at,
this is what you're gonna do. If this,
if this is the standard that you
want, okay, I will go with it.
And you can call Brady had
cheater in the Patriots to cheer,
but then we're going to go
through the whole fucking league.
And this is just the shit that I know
cause I've got shift from some fucking
Steeler fan. Right. And I'm like really?
Well if we're just going to go
on circumstantial evidence, uh,
you have a sex offender at,
at the QB precision two times sex offender
that we know of at the QB position
and also Terry Bradshaw admitted to doing
steroids along with a bunch of other
Steelers in the 70s. So you're no longer
six Berg, you're fucking two time,
two t two times sex offender,
two time super bowl champion Berg.
You want that?
What about Jerry Rice who admitted after
his career that he used to stick them?
That wasn't quite legal. It wasn't
fucking legal. So they had gone,
what did he went three titles with the
40 niners though is the route and the 40
niners are all cheaters. You can
go around the fucking league. This,
this shit in the league that you don't
even fucking, there's been no evidence.
You know why there's no evidence
is because the other team,
that loss was never such a fucking pussy
like Jim or say that they launched an
investigation.
Do you think that you can't do this
to every fucking team on every game?
If you looked under every fucking jock
strap, you wouldn't find something.
Let's look at the Dallas cowboys in
the early nineties their head coach was
Jimmy Johnson Bank Bank,
bank bank, bank bank,
Jimmy Johnson from the University
of fucking Miami. Okay.
Basically a low security
federal fucking prison.
That's what their football program
was when he was running it.
Then he goes to dad,
The Dallas Cowboys,
Aka a coq 10 slash whorehouse
of a fucking franchise.
Their owner has a face
lift. His face, his ally,
his face is cheating right out of
the gate. The first thing you fuck,
you're telling me if he didn't look under
a couple of those cheerleaders skirts,
you wouldn't have found something. Give
me a fucking break. I'll tell you right.
If this guy gets fucking suspended,
this is an absolute God damn fucking
travesty that you're going to do this tar
and feather,
one of the greatest quarterbacks of
all time and arguably the greatest head
coach of all time with this country
fucking pussy. Shit. I, I can't,
I, I, I don't even, I think I
won't watch professional football.
I'm just going to watch college football
this year. If this is what happens if,
because of a bunch of fucking
sore losers and mouth breathing,
fucking morons complain enough.
I swear to God,
I really think it's because all that
ray rice shit, you know what I mean?
Or they didn't get a rug.
We've got to get it right.
Ray Rice knocks out his fiance and the
guy I two two games, two game suspension.
Why don't you cool it out there? Uh,
you know, uh, you know, come on man,
we can't have this. We can't, you know,
they fucking talk to him like Henry
Hill when he had his Goumarre, you know,
they came over it. Come on, you've
got to go back to your wife. Okay.
We can't have this. This is
ridiculous. All right, come on.
You can't be standing over here.
He got to go back to Karen.
That's how they treated them,
right?
Then all of a sudden the video came out
and they were like, oh, wait a minute. We,
uh, we met. Uh, we don't
tolerate that and, uh,
get out of the league, get
out of the league because
we're so fucking pure, right?
It's all fucking bullshit. It's all
bullshit. Right? And then fucking, uh,
then what happens is God damn fiance,
who should have left the guy,
you know, that's probably it. That's
probably grounds to be like, you know,
this really isn't what I'm looking
for in a relationship. She goes,
but she forgives the guy.
Why did she forgive him?
Because he gave the apology or the fucking
university because he makes a zillion
dollars a fucking year. Do you think of
Ray Rice was working at Midas Muffler?
The forgive this happens. I
don't think it does. Coming home.
Everyday smell and like fucking exhaust.
I don't think it does. It's all bullshit.
That stupid pink shit that they
make an a zillion dollars off of.
You guys go out and buy that fucking
those Pink Jersey and you seem to think
you're helping out cause your grandmother
died a fucking breast cancer and you
find that like one half of one half of
one fucking percent actually goes to the
cause to raise awareness,
not even to fight the disease.
And the rest goes into these
fucking owner's pockets.
Do you see that shit about the troops?
Whenever the advertise with the fucking,
uh, the flag and all that you thinking,
wow. The NFL supporting the troops.
The military's got to pay for that.
You guys are talking about a
container out of a fucking ball.
So we said this weekend
said if he actually did it,
he should have just said
like, yeah man, I like that.
That's what the fuck I like him at.
Gives me a little better field, you know?
Okay.
I didn't think it was that big a deal.
And then you combine that with the fact
that ESPN did the study and showed it
was actually a disadvantage.
And you combine it with the fact that
when he had the regulation fucking ball,
he scored each keep fucking killed
him even worse. So fucking witch hunt,
you tar and feather on this guy and you
know what? Go ahead and fucking do it.
Cause that's what sports fans do.
It's like New York sports fans,
New York sports fans, you know, all they
bring up when they talked to Boston fans,
uh, the two giant victories over the
patriots so you couldn't beat the giants.
Doe Cook does still bringing that
shit up. You know, it's like,
I don't even bring up the fucking oh four
Yankees. Do I do that? Do I bring up, uh,
you know, oh the fucking Celtics
got 17 championships. Do I fucking,
the only time I ever do that is
if a Knicks fan comes up to me.
It gives me fucking shit.
Fucking New York fence
sitting there ignoring,
hanging their hats on to fucking wins in
fucking ignoring the absolute carnage,
the roadkill, this sports roadkill
of the other fucking eight teams,
the other 18 in your fucking state
roadkill fucking roadkill to the point.
They shouldn't even be
there in a fucking league.
Okay.
Horrific. Absolutely fucking
horrific. And even your crown jewel,
the Yankees, they blew a three
games to none leagues. Even.
They've got a fucking big sploosh of
mud in their face. Fucking unreal.
I'm fucking real.
I got to listen to oversee all fucking
week this week talking about how to tell
him Boston fans, how the fucking giants
beat the fucking patriots. It's just like,
it really, I've always still talking
about the fucking whatever. Hey,
you know what good for you.
Good on you.
Did you went to what we want for
while winning three world series,
a Stanley Cup in an NBA championship
with four teams. I will take that.
I'll take those two losses all fucking
day long. All Day long. But anyways,
so this past Thursday,
so I was fucking rag and about this
Brady shit as I just as I just did and I
don't want to hear anybody
giving me any shit about that.
It continued to talk about
this cause you cause, uh,
continuing to talk about it on the other
side. Tar and feather in my fucking guy.
So I'm going to stick up for
him here. Um, so anyways,
other than the Brady thing,
last Thursday,
the fucking lightning were up three
games to none against the Canadians.
And the fucking capital's were up
three games to one against the New York
rangers and all I was thinking as well,
at least before that was thinking all
right, well if the rangers, Canadians,
when they play each other,
so they're gonna knock one of them out.
So now I'm down to just one. Um, you know,
and then hopefully the ducks are the
Blackhawks. We'll finish them off, right?
But all of a sudden it looked like Tampa
Bay was going to win and the capital's
we're going to fucking win.
Okay.
You know, and, and they will, they,
they were going to get done
away with in the sammies. Oh,
I don't want it made me feel great.
And then what happens?
Canadians win game four.
Alright, did the Canadian,
so you got that fucking pride
that got that tradition.
You think you're going to sweep us? Go
Fuck Yourself. All right, come on Tampa.
Finish them off from five.
They fucking win game five.
Well they have to game six right now.
So Games six is tonight game six,
six tonight. And I'm going
to tell you right now, Tampa,
yeah,
I swear to God. Eisenman's gotta be
down there. He's got to go down there.
He's got to give him a speech because
if they lose, this one is fucking over.
You can never say it's over,
but it is fucking over.
MMM.
And I actually think, I think
I'm rooting for the capitals,
but I think the range of series is over.
I think it's fucking over the
fucking goddamn capital's man.
They just can't get over the hump. You
know? You know what's funny? It was,
I really agreed when they got
rid of their fucking coach there.
I didn't think he was the right
guy. Uh, I can't remember his name.
It gives a B now he's with the
ducks. Guess I was wrong. Huh?
They're looking like the
favorites. So anyways, it's,
it's actually going to be a,
I think we're probably going to be
looking at to games seven. Um, you know,
as much as I root against the
fucking Canadians in the rangers,
it's actually exciting to watch a
team come back like that. And uh,
and then also it's fucking extra hockey.
Okay.
You know,
so it was kind of a win win.
They either fucking dispose
of them quickly or I get to
watch more playoff games,
you know, God knows I got
the time. It's a Bruins fan.
God knows I got the fucking time.
Um,
so anyways, uh, I'm in the middle
of this run here in Boston,
which is really a fucking amazing thing
and I want to thank everybody who has
come out so far. I'm, I'm
really not taking this, uh,
this week lately. You know,
this means a lot to me that all these
shows were added and everybody comes out
and uh, and it's really
cool. Then I basically,
I started my career 23 years
ago right across the street,
or actually right across the
street now as the w hotel,
but he used to be an
empty parking lot and uh,
you could actually see Nick's comedy
stop. It was great. They had this,
they still have the sign and it lights up.
It's just blocked by the hotel now.
See, can't fucking see it. And they're
actually down to only two shows a week,
which kind of makes me sad,
but I got to tell you,
I'm like one of the few guys I know
that the original place where I started,
um, actually, uh,
still exists and is doing comedy. That's
pretty good. 23 years. And, and uh,
I tell you, I did so much stand up
in this fucking state, you know,
it was mother's Day yesterday, happy
mother's Day to all the mothers and uh,
took my mom out to brunch and all that
and mixed up my other relatives and stuff.
We all met at this restaurant and I
went in there and I was just like,
Jesus Christ, I did stand up in this,
this space. It wasn't this restaurant,
but it was something else
like fucking 20 years ago.
And then the place right next to it
used to be like a ground round or a
Spaghetti Freddy's or something like that.
And I used to do stand up
in the basement of that. Um,
all these fucking memories
coming back. Um, you know,
great memories. Some sad, you know,
I always think about Patrice when I
come back here. He still, he's fucking,
I used to swing by, uh, you know,
I'd go blue hill lab and I would
turn, he lived down on, uh,
where did they live?
On Seaver street in West Roxbury.
I used to go down there and I pick
them up. We drive over. No did,
I used to pick him now.
He used to go into the clubs and then
I'd meet him in at the clubs and at night
I'd give him a ride home. And, uh,
so just thinking about all
of that shit and all the
fucking, uh, I don't know, man.
It's been,
it's been one of those things and not
just a bunch of people that I went to high
school with and, uh, I've been showing
up, which is always great, you know?
And, uh, fortunately I had a really,
you know, some people, you know,
due to the high school, it hit
him with fucking great. I didn't,
I loved high school, I hated the
academic part, but I came a really good,
cool grade.
And fortunately everybody I've run into
is doing really well and they're happy.
And what's really cool too
is they seen the exact same,
I ran into a couple of kids the
other night, not even kids now. Shit,
we're fucking mid forties and uh,
it's crazy.
Everyone I run into for my grade, it was
just like, you know, 25, 27 years in,
some cases have gone by.
He just pick up,
right where you left off talking
about is hey, you know, they got kids,
whatever they're doing,
and then you just start talking
about all the dumb shit that we did.
Had a couple buddies of mine
come in last night and I'm not going
to name the name of the school.
Uh,
he was, he had this, I'll tell you the
quick version of the story. All right?
It's the late eighties. Appetite
for destruction is just catching on.
People are playing the
fucking cassette tape.
We're at this party to
have my psycho friends.
One of them's gone now rest his soul.
They go to go upstairs, you know,
to go to a different party,
all right?
They both leave fucking 10
minutes later they come back.
One of them had a flat top.
He had a fucking gash going,
like almost like someone tried to
parties hair by splitting the scalpel.
He's got this fucking four inch Gash on
top of his head and the other guy's got
a separated shoulder and a fat lip.
And we're like, what the fuck happened?
They're like, oh, you know, we just
walked into this party. We said, hey,
is this a party? And they just
started beating us up, right?
So this fucking mob goes
up the Goddamn stairs,
right? And uh, we, you know, we're
going up the stairs, all drunk,
and we hear the party and the biggest
psycho out of all of us knocked on the
door. And, and the person who knows how it
goes, hello? And he goes, hey, excuse me,
say a party in here.
And the fucking dude opened the door
and then it just fucking bedlam.
I'll never forget the sound of that.
Cause it was all hardwood floors.
It was like fucking what
appeared to be 20 on 20.
Everybody throwing fucking haymakers
and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Long story short,
the fucking smoke clears and I'm kind
of looking over at the people we were
fighting and it's like six guys and six
women and there's a board game that's
fucking all over the place. Uh,
we went to the wrong part, right?
They were in there playing like risk or
something. And then 20 drugs came in,
just wasn't 20. It was like, I dunno,
it was like eight of us. And uh,
I dunno, the real party was upstairs.
It was funny. It was the kids upstairs,
they actually sued my friends cause
what they said happened didn't really
fucking happen.
So we would talk in about
just all of those days,
there's so many funny details of some
of my friends and I don't want to share
them all with you because I'm afraid
someone else is going to steal it and put
it in a script. Cause there's a couple
of details from these guys. First,
he's always like, dude,
that's fucking hilarious.
You've got to put that
in something. But, uh,
so we were just talking about
all those old days and uh,
oh my God,
that guy got mad at the other guy and
he threw a keg right through his fucking
windshield.
I got arrested for drinking and driving
because I was trying to get home to the
fucking patriots rams game.
That was when I got pulled over and I
remember the cop pulled me over and he
said, where you coming from? And I
said, ah, fuck in Boston. He goes,
fucking Boston.
You want to get out of the car please?
And I play with what a shit
show I ever want to have.
Fucking was trying to
put my finger to my nose.
It from fucking eight to 12 went
good as far as the arm movement.
But when I went 12 to six,
it felt like somebody else's hand just
came down and slap me in the head and he
goes,
you want to turn around and face the car
and put your arms out and try to stand
on one that he was just trying
to get me to end the position.
He just fucking cuff me. Uh, it was bad.
It was bad at a one nine,
you know,
thought they had the two thought I
had the two. All right, let's do this.
A little more advertising here. That's
good. Fucking convicted drunk driver.
Here we go.
Let's do some advertising here and he's
not even talking about the dangers of
it. All right? Legal Zoom, everyone.
Are you the next world?
Famous entrepreneur or maybe
you don't care about fame,
you just want to help people. Whatever
your motivation, if you're an innovator,
it's easy to launch your dream
this month with legal zoom.
Incorporate or form an LLC
to start your business.
Register your trade Mac to protect
your products and services.
Apply for a patent to secure
your invention or over the
over the past decade and
a legal zoom has helped more than a
million people just like you turn their
ideas into reality.
So what's special about this month?
Well, for a limited time, you can get,
as you can get special savings
on any trademark copyright,
a provisional patent application,
go to legalzoom.com today to get started.
They even can help you
if you have a great idea,
but you're not sure where to begin
since they're not a law firm law firm,
you can get advice from legalzoom's
network of independent attorneys in most
states.
That means you can get the guidance you
need to get your idea off of the ground.
Don't forget to enter bar in the referral
box at checkout this month for your
special discount,
legalzoom.com Promo Code Berbee
you are our legal help is here.
All right, stamps.com everyone.
Uh, lastly, but not least,
the most of us are trying
to find more time everyday.
Get everyday to get things done so you
can't let trips to the post office slow
you down now you now you don't have to.
Thanks to stamps.com with stamps.com you
can buy and print official US postage
right from your own computer
and printer stamps.com.
We'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates the exact postage
you need for any letter or package.
Any class of male.
You'll never waste valuable time
going to the post office again.
Do everything right from your desk with
stamps.com print the postage you need,
uh,
put it on your letter or package and then
just hand it to your mail carrier and
you know what? You're all done. I use
stamps.com to send out all my posters,
like the little, the fucking one
I'm selling this week at the Wilbur.
I'm autographed poster, by the way,
if you're coming down, uh, right now,
use my last name,
birth for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandinberbeeyouarethatstamps.com
enter
Burr, right? Mercifully,
the reading out loud portion
of the program is over. Um,
oh for fuck's sakes, what
happened? I, I, you know something,
I absolutely fucking 100% hate computers.
I had all my questions.
What happened? What does it mean when
you click on it now? There it is.
There it is. I like, I was just
going to ask you that. Like,
you could answer me on a
recording. Alright. Fed Up. Hey,
bill saw a great documentary called,
fed up.
A few things they talked about sounded
like stuff you'd mentioned on the podcast.
I was wondering if you've seen it.
It focuses on the dangers of sugar and
the addiction that most Americans have.
Definitely check it out if you
haven't. Um, no, I've read enough on,
I read, I even rent, I
mean read a little bit,
but I'm mostly watched a bunch
of documentaries and, uh,
I've pretty much found
that there they are. Uh,
they're right on. They're
very active. I tell you,
it's very difficult to try to eat food
now that has not been tampered with on
some level. And, uh,
I try to be empathetic to the people
that grow the food. Thinking like, well,
you know, if you got to feed 7
billion Goddamn people or whatever,
300 whatever there is in
this country though, 300
something million, 400 million,
you know,
you're gonna need some pesticides.
Um, but, um, you know,
I'm trying not to talk on my cell
phone anymore with it up to my head.
I don't go through that airport security
with a fucking use that, you know,
x Ray light thing that they're using. I
don't go through that thing. Um, I just,
I don't fuck with any of that stuff.
I tried to avoid that as much as I can
while all the time drinking way too much
and occasionally smoking a cigar.
So I'm the typical fucking hypocrite.
We're in this room.
I am talking holier than now and then
in the other room I'm a fucking devil.
So I dunno, I, I recommend
that people watch that stuff.
You just take what you can from it.
Uh,
maybe you think it's total bullshit and
he keep on eating Twix bars and fucking,
you know, whatever the fuck else you
want to eat. Um, you know, have at it,
whatever it, she'll body folding
it, whatever you want to do.
But I'm not going to be that
person wagging your finger going,
we need to stop these people. They're
poisoning fucking people. You know,
I let somebody else do that.
Somebody else wants to fucking lead
the march down the Goddamn road. I'll,
I'll be there. Will I? I don't
know. I have no idea. Oh God.
Henry Jackson would fucking slapped
me in the face with this powdered wig.
All right girl with no
name. Hey, big balls. Billy.
I was in New Orleans for
jazz fest last weekend, man.
And I met an absolutely gorgeous girl.
Wow, that's already a great story.
Went to a music festival in of
one of the great music cities,
probably the best music city in the
goddamn country. Relaxed Nashville.
Um, and you met a beautiful woman.
That's awesome. I like this already.
This is a movie I'm watching.
The first 10 pages I'm in. Uh,
we immediately hit it off last Saturday
and had a phenomenal night together in
the French quarter.
The next day we didn't get,
we exchanged numbers and said our goodbyes
as she lives in California and I'm in
Florida. Oh, this entire,
this entire last week.
We've been texting nonstop to each
other and I'm beginning to fall into the
first stages of love with the scale. The
problem is I did not remember her name,
but she has used mine
repeatedly. Ah, fuck dude.
We both enjoyed jobs where we have
where we traveled quite a bit,
so we are planning on having a
George Clooney slash vera Farmiga.
I Dunno.
In up in the air type relationship.
We were planning on meeting up in
New York, our memorial day week.
My problem is I don't know the best
way to figure out what her name is.
I feel like straight up asking her name
at this point would make me come across
as a total douche bag and risk
jeopardizing the relationship.
Dude at that means that some
point in the French quarter,
you've already forgotten her
fucking name. Oh God. Fucking,
oh my God. This is making
me feel nervous. Also,
I am afraid that continuing using pronouns
as I have them will get me in trouble
sooner than later.
When this happened in the past,
I would just tell the girl to add me
on Facebook to get her name that way.
However,
I was forced to delete my Facebook
account in my previous relationship,
a move. I am regretting more and more
each day and any help on a suave way,
I can attain this girl's name without
coming across as a chauvinist asshole.
Wouldn't be much appreciated as always.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Well there's nothing chauvinist.
Stick above forgetting the name. Um,
and why did you have to delete
your account? What happened?
Hell hath no fury.
What did you do that you do something?
Because I would just say, well why don't
you just add your account back up again?
This is what you should do you have any,
I already talked about it on Facebook.
Yeah.
Just text her and say, oh no. Yeah,
I can't say where. Where's your
account? She'd be, it's under my name.
MMM.
This is what I would do.
Oh Jesus.
I would add,
this is why this isn't what you
fucking do. This is what you do.
Just create an account
under a different name,
like your nickname or something stupid,
you know, and you can just say like,
ah,
you know,
I just think sometimes he's social
network things are a little invasion,
an invasion of privacy and just,
ah,
man, I don't know. This is tricky. She'd
be like, well, just add me sound my name.
Do you know what my fucking
name is? Uh, boy. Um,
all right guys,
we're going to need some fucking help on
this one because I'm failing miserably.
You only thing I can think of
is get back on fucking Facebook.
MMM.
But when you get back on Facebook,
she's gonna be like, well,
why didn't you just go
over and fucking add me?
Is she on Twitter?
Ask her what a Twitter handle this.
There's gotta be a way to
do it through social media.
Okay.
I really feel at this point that I don't
know that you can fucking ask her what
her name was. It's too fucking long at
this point to ask her what her name is.
And also to be honest with you,
the fact that he had delete your account,
you know,
and you've done this before in the past.
You sound to me like you kind
of out there crushing it.
So I really don't feel
too, too bad for you. Um,
and also you probably just from
a couple of details in that,
whatever the fuck you did.
Um,
I dunno dude.
I mean, who the fuck did you date
Glenn? Close in fucking, uh, you know,
you got cheese and you've knows
whatever the fucking movies called.
Okay.
The attraction. Fatal attraction, right?
MMM.
Who's getting Whoa, dude, you
fucked around. And the other girl,
and then she just was saying
you were cheating piece of shit.
That's what I'm guessing.
And then you had to get off Facebook.
Right? So you did that.
You fucked her friend.
Yeah,
Dude. Fuck this other
girl. What did you do?
I want to know I wanna I want
the second installment of this.
What did you do to get kicked off of
Facebook now that you had to take off your
account because of a
previous relationship?
Huh?
I can tell you right now, dude,
I dunno what the fuck you did,
but you're never going to be able to run
for political office until you address
this part of your life right now, sir.
All right. Uh, but other than that,
I would try to maybe somehow
through fucking Jesus Christ.
How do you do it?
It'd be fucking drunk.
Rummaging through her purse when
she goes into use the bathroom.
Okay.
Oh God. You know, I, I would judge you
if I hadn't done all of that, you know.
All right. Best athletes, Billy boy,
I tried that boxing workout that
you talked about on the show.
A run for three minutes.
Then rest for a minute. Oh,
now run for three minutes.
I said skip rope for three minutes
and rest for a minute for 12 rounds.
Kicked my ass. Thanks for
the tip. Uh, in your opinion,
what sport has the best
all around athletes?
MMM,
best all around athletes.
Okay.
Uh, you know, I don't know. I think
they're all fucking on me. I'll tell you.
As far as physical condition.
MMM.
I W hockey players that are,
have you ever seen,
we were talking about that comics
come home. I forget who said it.
I want to give it the comic credit.
I've can't remember what it was,
but it wasn't me.
It was another comic who said that says
you never see a fat hockey player and
it's fucking true. And if you've
ever played the sport, you know why?
MMM.
You just don't, it's just, it's
of those sports where it's just,
you just burn so much calories.
You have to be in such unbelievable
physical condition that you,
uh, what does that sound?
Um, was that a bird?
It was a fucking bird outside
making this weird noise.
Every time I inhaled I thought I
had a problem with my chest. No,
I hear that again.
What is that?
Okay.
Is it the bed? Are you guys
hearing it? Is it in my head?
But what am I losing my mind anyways?
The,
I dunno, those UFC guys are fucking
unbelievable. Boxes are unreal.
I have no idea.
Jesus Christ.
What a shit show that fucking
Pacquiao Mayweather fight was, huh?
Everybody's flipping the fuck out about
that thing for as he's convinced it's
fixed. Listen to the verse he effect this
week. He sits there going like, dude,
you could see it like when
packy I'll puts his head down.
I'm sitting there going,
well you don't think he put his head
down during the press conference because
everyone was bitching that they,
they got fucked over on the
fight and he was embarrassed.
I don't think that automatically
means that there was fixed, but hey,
I like a conspiracy like
anybody. So anyways. All right.
How the fuck do I get out of this?
Let's just fucking go on to the next
God damn question. I'll read this thing.
I swear to God, I think I'm making that
noise when I breathe in. All right.
In love with the lesbian. Oh,
you fucking romantic full.
Um,
hey bill saw your show in Memphis and I
just wanted to say you fucking killed it.
Thank you.
I drove all the way from Arkansas
and was stoked to meet you and get an
autographed poster. Uh,
well thank you. Anyways,
I just wanted to get your
take on of my weird situation.
There's this girl I've liked since I
started Grad school and we've known each
other for four years. She's
fun, intelligent, kind in
my eyes at least. Beautiful.
Well, why'd you have to fucking
qualify it? Their thing is,
I found out early on she
didn't play for the team.
I thought she didn't play for the team.
I thought she did. I was devastated.
Soon after that,
the woman she loved died and
she's still case taking care of,
said woman's kids from a previous
relationship. Since then, I've moved away.
I've tried a bunch of things to try
and get over, you know the usual shit.
Jim Bury yourself and work.
Go after other ladies.
I visited her intermittently
in the past four years.
Well that's not good for you and I
can't seem to stop caring for her.
Would love to hear what you would
do if you were in my situation.
Thanks again and go fuck yourself.
Um,
I think you just have to deal with the
fact that you're in love with someone
that's not going to love you and you
need to move on and just keep doing what
you're doing. Keep going to the
gym, bury yourself in your work.
I wouldn't bury yourself in work.
Who the fuck wants to work all the time.
But yeah,
instead of going after other ladies,
why don't you try to go find one that
you have something in common with.
All right. Thank you. If you
had to make a list right now,
somebody you would looking for to
spend the rest of your life with,
I don't think being a lesbian would be
on that list because she's not going to
get with you unless a, I dunno if
she feels like living a lie. Right.
Wrote at some point. You know what I
mean? She's going to go get her hair done.
Uh,
what would I would do?
I would have faced in the fact that
you're the right person is going to come
into your life. Ah, I would stop with
the visits because that's just, you know,
that's like going back and
hitting the crack pipe. You know,
you're fucking Charlie Brown
tried to kick the football again.
You fucking land on your back
and you get back up. And what do,
what are you doing? You
know, I would just, uh,
you know, I think if you want
to fucking meet somebody nice,
you have to start living a nice life
yourself. You know what I mean? Like,
what's funny is, you know, you see
these dance clubs, Baby B, B, B, B, B,
B. Nobody meets their wife or
husband in there, you know,
fucking roofie central,
you know,
everybody on fucking drugs
and glow sticks. I mean,
you just got a bunch of fucking,
you know, either immature,
a damaged people in there. You
don't put a baby in that. Well,
you don't accept somebody fucking
Goddamn baby batter us disgusting.
Uh, you just, yeah, get the fuck out of
there. Okay. You don't meet your wife,
you know,
and black light.
Yeah,
I would. Um, I don't know.
There's a lot of stuff that you can do
in your 20s to actually meet a great
person that you never really think of
doing it because you think you've got to
go out and you want to go out to bars.
You want to do all that crazy shit,
get it out of your fucking system. But
if you actually, you know, I dunno,
join like some sort of league play sports
or do some volunteer work or something
like that, you're going to meet a great
person, you know, or a fun person.
Stay out of those stupid ass
fucking clubs that every guy,
every mouth brie that goes to,
you know the kind of people that are
going to get Brady a two game suspension
for a cunt hair of a fucker.
Unbelievable. Who the fuck ways the balls.
Can you guys just set aside
your hatred for the Patriots?
Can you just set a set aside
and then just sit there and,
and on any fucking level as a fucking man,
admit to what?
The level of crybaby
horse shit that that is.
Okay.
Unfucking believable.
I'm trying to think of anybody that
throws a ball that doesn't doctorate every
fucking pitcher does. Every
quarterback does. They scuffed them up.
They do all kinds of fucking shit
to get them where they like it.
A little fucking little
English on the Goddamn Ball.
They all fucking do it every goddamn
one of them. He's got a fucking ritual.
How they like their football.
Do you honestly think that the reason
why you didn't make it to the NFL was
because the ball was
in fully inflated day.
The next time you play a pickup game,
why don't you let a little bit of air
out of the ball and all of a sudden it
will magically go everywhere
where you fucking wanted to go?
You'd be throwing like Tom Brady.
It doesn't even fucking make any sense.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Oh my God,
this will make you guys non
patriots fans fun. Happy. Yeah.
I will never get over this if they fucking
tar and feather him over this fucking
horse shit.
And then I want all the you who support
it rather than being pussies on the
fucking Internet.
Come out to my show or what are you
gonna have to go to the shelf just
afterwards.
I really want you to look me in the eye
and present your argument as to why you
really fucking field that.
That like gave him an advantage.
I really want to fucking know why.
Like what fucking advantage.
And you'd be going against an impartial
scientists because ESPN hired the person
and God knows ESPN is in
the game of sensationalism.
They didn't want that guy to fucking come
up with a study that said it wasn't an
advantage. Um, they wanted it
to say it wasn't advantage.
And you know why I know that is because
they're completely ignoring the fact
that they had that study done
on their own fucking network.
Okay.
Hello? I'll tell you, it bugs me,
you know, all right. Dilemma. Um,
your podcasts and none
of them. Uh, all right.
So here's the dilemma for you. Uh, would
you rather spend a year in jail? No.
Yeah.
Having to sleep in the same cell cell
with the gay fellow named Mandingo Jones.
Oh, Jesus. Is that the most
hackiest fucking thing ever? Um,
well,
I tell you,
I'd rather have a gay cellmate than a
fucking angry straight one that wants to
fucking,
you know,
you just feel like the gay guy would
be a little more gentle. You know,
he's been there before. He's got
some technique gross. All right?
Or would you rather become
a piece of shit banker?
Okay,
do, that's not it. It's not a dilemma.
I for fucking become a banker.
Then I'd be a mole and I'd fucking Rad
everybody out. Even then I couldn't,
I couldn't fucking rat people out.
I'd just be going like guys, you know,
remember that day you remember
David spades bit when he used,
when he was imitating Michael J.
Fox and a,
okay,
come on,
let's not rape this girl in Vietnam.
Whatever the fucking movie was
called. Was it guys? You know,
what are we doing here sarge? Like
that's what I would be that guy. I mean,
although this is a part of me that would
like to be sitting in on those meetings
just to hear what the fucking, just to
hear what they said. You know what I mean?
How they present.
Do they literally present it like let's
do something illegal or do they use
other words where everybody just realizes
what they're presenting is not exactly
within the boundaries and a little
game and ship gamesmanship and banking.
I want to how they feel it feel like,
you know, although I got to tell you, um,
2008 was definitely spygate
when it was fucking, uh,
you know, when it was fucking, you
know, whatever the fuck they did. They,
when they oh artificially over
inflated the prices of the House,
this $40,000 house is worth
fucking 90 grand and you what?
You make $9 a month and
you're qualified for a loan.
Um, anyways, whatever
Patriot anti Patriot fans,
you want to fucking give
a shit for spy gate.
I'll take that all day long and
they shouldn't have done it. It was,
it was cheating. They should
not have done that. All right.
There's a league wide memo telling
everybody to stop doing it in the arrogant
cunt continued to do it.
I think he was guilty of arrogance.
I think if he was actually cheating,
I think he would have used something a
little smaller than some giant news TV
thing fucking standing right
there on the goddamn sideline.
But if you want to say it's
that, then you know, fine.
If you fucking guys want to act like
your team does not do stuff to get a
competitive fucking edge.
Think about all the guys who
are barely in the fucking NFL,
barely in the fucking NFL.
And if they fucking get cut,
they're going to go to bag and God damn
groceries that a fucking Gelson's you
know, or even worse of
violence or a roach brothers,
right? Or, or you know,
they could maybe do a little something.
Maybe Grab Jersey here.
Maybe put a little sticky
stuff on the gloves. Little,
I'm not talking about roids here.
Not Talking about Roy.
All right. Brady got busted for doing
steroids. Fine. Yes, you're cheating.
All right. Absolutely. But if
you're talking about little land,
a little fucking a, let's do a little
this too little that each fucking play.
If you're gonna fucking call that
cheating, I mean, you're really going to,
you kind of fun. You're going to
fucking kill everybody in the league.
I would say that's what I would say.
I know you fucking sick of it.
You think I'm a patriots fan? I am,
and I'm definitely fucking bias,
but I think I'm right as to you.
So what are we going to toe here?
Agree to disagree?
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a wonderful week and I'll
check in on you on Thursday. There.